All right, this time we're going to do just a tiny bit differently.
What we're going to do is we're going to search this graph starting from b
and we're going to mark as we go the order in which we've added things to the open list.
So, we started off with b, the only thing on the open list, we visit both the neighbors of b
add them to the open list, pull c off the open list, add it's neighbors d, b,
and we work on d, take it off the open list, add its neighbors e and c.
Now, we can take e off the open list, add its neighbors f and, well this is already done.
Take f off the open list, add its neighbors g and this is already done.
Take g off the open list, its neighbors are all already done, nothing is added.
Take a off the open list, its neighbors are already done, okay, we're finished.
So, I want you to do this starting from d and make a note of the numbers
as you add them and let me clean this up, okay.
I want you to try this just like I did starting from d this time and write the numbers underneath,
and when you're finished, when the search is completed,
take whatever number you have under a, take whatever number you have under g,
add them together, and put it in this box here.